just kidding hi it worked out really
well
hi Internet welcome to my mom's kitchen
I'm wearing an Irish soccer jersey that
someone gave to me Murray and knives I
am so sorry that I am so popular it's
work
oh hi my name is grace not like if you
did not know now you know your life is
different now everyone after Christmas
does a lot know what I got for Christmas
video so I thought I joined in because
ah I'm a sheep here are some of the
things that I got for Christmas this is
not just the world's most impractical
dildo this is a magic wand my brother
got me this it's most often a children's
toy but I'm I'm a child I am I'm a child
how do they let me drive cars I don't
know but this is really cute thanks Jim
cute him also got me yeah I don't know
that person that's not a person that I
know at all this is an ornament that was
being sold at a place up in Boston's and
he thought I would like it very much
and he's right this is weird and I like
it very much thank you Jim like
identical necks this is the gift for my
dad and my stepmom my family this year
went for like slightly more personalized
gifts I think it's more fun that way and
so they got me this time to put outside
that says grace is paradise for it's
always five o'clock some people might
call this enabling I call this love
Hussein cheeseburgers in paradise that
song speaks to me on a very spiritual
level I don't know what the actual
meaning of the song is and just know
cheeseburgers in paradise
it could be about a really tormented
love I don't care give me some
cheeseburgers in Grace's paradise oh and
it's got a crab just like me haha
kidding I only have a dog next yeah that
does Grace's backyard barn grills it's
2016 this is also from
my stepmom because they just really want
me to throw parties I think they think I
need to expand my social circles who
knows this is a nice bucket or a bucket
for any holdings of anything but you can
put ice in this and then put a bunch of
beers and so does the waters or whatever
you want
if this internet thing doesn't work out
I can really just transform my backyard
into a functional restaurant but we only
serve cold beer that's that no food but
I thought this was cute and it's very
much on theme with graceful parties so
you get friends thank you parents next
yeah this is from my mother these are
jumbo sized googly eyes well I have a
normal Christmas tree when you can have
a real creepy kind of pervy and
terrified looking Christmas tree my mom
knows how to interior decorate but you
can put them anywhere so that's gonna be
really fun thanks mom Jack's peas my mom
got me some socks that say don't get
your tinsel in a tangle and dude is a
cat wearing tinsel and antler ears and I
thought those were really cute but she
got everyone's socks and I guess I was
the only one that didn't put them on
right away because I was already wearing
other socks and she thought that I
needed this gift so mom I like this gift
I just I only have so many pairs of
clean socks with makes I packed terribly
and so I need to save these to break in
case of emergency but my mom sat with
that sadness for like a day without
telling me that she thought I didn't
like the socks because I didn't put them
on immediately and because Tim did
shocked him and now in the last thing
that's it oh my god we're already at the
end I guess so while ago and I was here
my mom showed me a [ __ ]
that I mentioned was funny and I don't
really remember it vaguely remember it
but she remembered it so she took a
photo of the [ __ ] and then she had it put
onto a blanket and it says and not a
single was given that day and then it
just was really kind of pretentious but
like ultimately Barry stops my cat just
bopping through a field not giving any
not a single one and this is on the
blanket now so thank you mom cute with
all these new personalized gifts my
house is really gonna start giving off
some mixed signals 2017 look out or
don't come hang out with me but I'm not
gonna give up
about it if you don't okay thank you for
watching this video if you enjoyed this
at all please hit subscribe to this
channel I know I'm imposed to kind of
inconsistently lately but it's been
holidays and also like I don't have a
single love to give as how I'm choosing
to n 2016 maybe it'll be another video
before the end of the year but we'll see
no promises people with no
disappointment I don't know what did the
sheep that hit a Christmas say bah
humbug I hate myself that whole sentence
it was very long and very telling like
more revealing than the rest of the
sheep were ready to deal with on a
personal level with that sheep they just
knew that he was always kind of angry
but they weren't ready to have like the
conversation of why but also in
hindsight it was nice that he finally
started opening up about feelings